good afternoon everyone and welcome to
my talk it's always fantastic to come
back to Oslo I really love coming here
being here a few times now it's one of
my favourite places my wallet disagrees
with me but but I love it so my name is
Adam and I work for a company called
particular software we are the makers of
a product called
n service bus has anyone here heard of n
service bus wow that's most of you
that's really great to see so I'm not
going to be talking about that today but
I will say that at particular software
our mission as a company is to help
developers and organizations to build
complex software systems and in doing
that we talk to a lot of people so we
come to conferences like this and speak
to senior developers like yourselves we
hold workshops we do a lot of customer
support as part of our in service bus
offering and we talk to people about
complicated gnarly technical problems
that are having with their systems and
it's very often we find that we we we
look at these problems and we think to
ourselves if the service boundaries were
a bit different some of these problems
may just fall away we may just not be
having having to have this conversation
at all and this happens so often it's
such a common theme that I think it's
really important to talk about finding
or service boundaries and how we can
find the best service boundaries for our
systems now I'm a well during this talk
take some of the ideas that you may be
familiar with some of the common
practices and the things we've been
trained to do as developers and I may
just kind of blow them out the water and
turn them upside down now if that's the
case do do challenge me on these things
I do like to be challenged on these
different ideas I don't know how much
chance we'll get to do a QA during this
session
to be honest I'm finding it difficult to
even see some of you but I am gonna be
around for the rest of the conference so
if you want to challenge me on some of
these ideas and ask me some more
questions about this weird stuff that
I'm going to be talking about please do
approach me please just grab me anytime
my twitter handle is on the top right as
well so you can tweet me anytime
I can open up a direct message channel
and we can have a chat we can even
arrange to meet somewhere so let's dive
in and look at a system so this is a
system it doesn't really matter what
system it is or what these things are if
you're a c-sharp program of these might
be classes but we tend to structure our
system into smaller pieces so we don't
just write a program domain and kind of
shove everything in there or at least I
hope we don't
I used to write programs that when I was
learning in the 80s but these days we
tend to structure things into smaller
things like classes or functions
directly if you're an f-sharp programmer
doesn't really matter now this looks
quite nice so we can see exactly kind of
what's calling what here and we can see
that there's kind of a sub module up
here that's doing something there's
another thing down here which is doing
something but at this point we haven't
actually drawn any strict boundaries so
this is just a bunch of classes acting
together to do some work now what tends
to happen is the business will come
along and ask for a new requirement and
you take a look anything okay I think we
can do this but what we really need to
do is we need to make a decision in the
class up here we need to make some kind
of change here and we need some data
that's located down here so how are we
gonna do this now
we could think about restructuring
things so we could think about moving
some responsibilities around and
changing things around or we could just
make a call from that class to that
class now this is kind of what classes
are designed for right classes designed
to have nice encapsulations with a nice
interface communicating their purpose so
you think okay well that's kind of going
to be okay we're not really messing the
diagram up much and it doesn't really
matter that we're making this call so
let's just try it and see if it sticks
so you make the call you roll out into
production and the business have got
their new feature they're happy and
you're happy and everything seems to
work sooner or later they might come
along with another requirement and they
might say well you know we need to do
something up here but we really need
some kind of piece of data that's in a
class down here and you think
that thing that we did three weeks ago
that kind of worked it didn't cause any
bugs it really caused any problem so in
retrospect is probably the right thing
to do is I think well should we just
kind of do the same thing again why
don't we just make a call from that
class to that class and we should be
okay you roll that out into production
there one's happy you're happy the
business is happy sooner or later you
find yourself having to do the same
thing and you can kind of see where this
might start to go over time and it might
be a long period of time you may be
working towards something like this
where kind of classes are calling
classes all over shop now the problem is
at this point it becomes difficult to
think about different parts of the
system in isolation so you kind of have
to if you want to make changes now you
have to kind of go on a kind of code
Safari so you can have delve into the
code try make some changes trying to
work out what class is calling what
class and you kind of hope you don't
introduce any bugs and you're operating
this kind of edit and prey mode of
operation kind of making edits and
praying that they're going to work and
it becomes and you get things working
you roll up your roll a new feature into
production and then your colleagues
might say to something like well did you
use a system diagram to help you I mean
you say what this thing that thing is
absolutely useless I can't make out I
can't make head or tail of this thing so
you can start to get the idea that the
different lines in the diagram don't
really mean much anymore you can't
really follow them you can't really
derive any meaning from them so you may
as well just take them out and draw a
bunch of boxes now at this point all
we've got really just a bunch of classes
and you can look at each class in
isolation and say okay this class is
doing this thing it has this nice name
it's got these properties in these
methods but when it comes to making a
change you're still operating on this
kind of code safari method of work you
kind of have to you have to look at
clumps of things and in at the same time
and try and work out what what a change
will affect in what class and what
classes are calling which class is and
it becomes difficult to actually look at
these things
in isolation you can't say Oh for this
new feature let's go and change that
class you still have to kind of try
things out and see so there's not really
much point drawing the individual boxes
anymore you may have just draw one big
box and at this point you kind of
realize that what you've actually got
now is what we sometimes call a big ball
of mud now has anyone seen this kind of
system at some time during their career
that's that's probably at least half of
you I have a lot so I've seen I would
say I've probably spent most of my
career working with the systems that
unfortunately have fallen into this
architectural pattern now we know we can
do better so we read about
service-oriented architecture and we
split our system into four services
let's say and what we want to do here is
we don't want each service to be
chatting constantly to another service
we don't want to be doing a whole live
request response between services and
sharing data around because that
wouldn't that would lead us down to a
road of tight coupling we want to have
small thin I've deliberately drawn these
very thin and not very many of them we
want to have lightweight communication
between the services so we don't end up
getting it back into a kind of big ball
of mud scenario now that's all well and
good but sooner or later the business
going to ask for a feature and you think
about it and you say well okay we can do
this but what we really need to do is to
share one tiny bit of data between the
top two services and it might be
something really innocuous like the
price of a product it's just a number
you know 99 kronor whatever it is how
much harm can that cause it's not really
making things tightly coupled we're not
really increasing the amount of
knowledge between those services very
much so you make that change roll out of
production everyone's happy
sooner or later you get another
requirement and you just cover you need
to share a bit of data between the two
left services and again it might be
something really innocuous it might be
something like inventory stock level of
a product so how many widgets have we
got 100 it's an integer what possible
harm can an integer calls
so you make that call and you roll that
out into production now you can see
where this might lead us over time and
this could be a large amount of time
it's not necessarily this is gonna
happen straightaway but over a large
amount of time we may start to move back
towards this kind of spaghetti spaghetti
type model we've got services calling
services and they're getting very chatty
and before we know we're back into the
big ball of mud scenario only this time
it's a big ball of mud with a difference
because we've split this into four
services we may have been rolling these
out into four different machines you've
now got a more complicated deployment
model you can't just roll out one thing
you might all that one two three or even
all four of at the same time they're
talking to each other over the network
even if it's localhost it's still a lot
less efficient than making in memory
class to class calls so we can actually
end up in a worse situation than when we
started with and that's a shame because
service-oriented architecture is
supposed to fix things for us so how can
we avoid coalescing back to this kind of
big born of mud scenario well let's have
a look at workflow I'm sure most of you
have bought something on Amazon at some
stage or something similar when you buy
something on Amazon you start a workflow
so you say place your order first of all
and then you might select your shipping
address you know where you can actually
get this way actually going to receive
this book whatever is the ordering you
put in your credit card details and etc
etc etc until you actually place your
order now Amazon is not a monolith it's
actually probably excuse me it's
actually probably one of the most
service-oriented companies in the world
there is not an one terabyte Amazon back
see that they roll out its a bunch of
different services so you can imagine
there's a lot of services going into
this workflow which are orchestrating
together to make this happen now if we
look at the events or look at the
backend messaging and events that happen
when you place your order it might look
something like this so we have here a
sales service a finance service and a
shipping service
when we click that button we can send
the command to the sales service to say
place your order sales can then go and
do whatever logic it needs to do have we
still got this item in stock as it's
still for sale if it's not in stock can
we order more etcetera etc and in the
end it says ok we're good to go the
orders been placed it can publish an
event which Finance and shipping can
subscribe to finance when it receives
that event it can bill the it can bill
the customer for that order it can raise
an order build event and then when
shipping knows that the orders been
placed the orders been billed we're good
to go
ship out the door raise another event
you know an auto ship with something
else then might want to carry on within
that workflow the question then is what
should each of these events contain
should the order placed event contain
all the information that shipping needs
in order to ship the item so the address
etc etc should the event contain all the
information that finance needs to
complete the order to build the customer
credit card details and that kind of
thing now that would work right that
would work but what's the problem with
that approach its coupling we're getting
back into a highly coupled situation if
that event needs to have the address the
shipping option the credit card details
and everything on it we can no longer
make changes in an isolated fashion we
want to change anything about how we
ship things or how we build for things
we're gonna have to make changes in
sales as well as finance or sales as
well as shipping imagine if we wanted to
start charging in Bitcoin we'd have to
give sales all the information about how
to charge in Bitcoin all the data that's
required so it could pass on that
information to finance what if we wanted
shot start shipping ebooks we don't send
an e-book to a physical address that
will just be weird so we don't want to
give that we don't want to give sales
all information about how about how we
should be an e-book so it can pass that
on to shipping
now what I just described our fad events
right and you can see that if we were to
start ship if we were to start shipping
ebooks and charging a Bitcoin that event
will get fatter and fatter and fatter
with more information on it
something's allowed to be null but other
things must not be null when they're
null and gets really complicated what we
want to do is have a look at how we can
get those fat events back down to thin
events with not much information on them
a much more loosely coupled system what
if we could get it down we could get
those events down to just an ID so what
if we said what if sales said order 1 2
3 has been placed finance says right
order 1 2 3 I know how to charge for
that order I'm going to charge a credit
card or I'm going to start a Bitcoin
transaction we then say order 1 2 3 has
been placed to shipping order 1 2 3 has
been billed to shipping an order and at
that point shipping can say right order
1 2 3 I'm going to ship that to a
physical address I'm going to send an
email now
that would work fine as well but we've
got a problem here if sales is
responsible for creating orders so sales
is the only thing that can say yes we
can feel the fulfill this order at that
point it will create an order object
with an ID and it will save it to its
database now how can finance possibly
know about that order before it's been
created how can finance know what to do
for order 1 2 3 if we're not creating
the order ID 1 2 3 until we create the
order in sales it's a chick in the next
scenario but the thing is what we've
said so far is we're going to create
that order at the end of the workflow
right so we're saying we're creating it
when we place the order what if we turn
that upside down and we create the ID
right at the beginning when we proceed
to the checkout we can do it right here
proceed to check and you can do this
client side as well right you can create
a good client side now what this allows
us to do is when we go into the rest of
the workflow we can say write shipping
here's the address and the order ID is 1
2 3 because we've already
for the order ID when we said when we
said place the place order when we go to
finance we can say right here the credit
card details for order one two three
such with sector etc until you get to
the end of the workflow is and that's
when you send that command to sales to
say place order now if you want to if
you want to introduce something like
Bitcoin payment we can make changes just
in the finance service because when
finance service gets order one two three
it can say ah I know how to charge wrist
it's either a credit card or its Bitcoin
and I can do the appropriate thing
similarly in shipping we can now ship
ebooks without having to make changes in
sales we can do that isolated just in
shipping and the one weird trick that
and they want us to do that was setting
the ID at the front instead of at the
beginning now you might be thinking what
if we tell the system where to ship our
order we tell them how to charge rear
but the last minute your spouse walks
through a door and they say ah now I'd
better not all of this that we mad so
you cancel the order you're closed a
browser shipping is going to be sitting
there with a whole bunch of addresses
which is never going to ship to finance
gonna is going to be sitting there with
a whole bunch of a bunch of payment
details which is never going to charge
for isn't that redundant data isn't
isn't someone gonna have to come along
and clean this data up we're gonna be
holding all that junk right but is it
really redundant so some businesses
would they would kill for that kind of
information they want to know who's
selecting products and where they want
into the shipment to but then don't
complete their order right because then
you can give that to kind of your design
team and your workflow team and you can
say well how can we make this better so
that more people actually go and create
actually go and fint finalize the order
so it can actually be really really
useful information you can get rich
business data analytics from that
incomplete order information storage you
know it's gonna be a row in a database
you know who really cares about how much
that's gonna cost but ultimately you
don't really have to keep it in a
database either so some services might
choose to hold it in some kind of
session state that might be more
applicable for finance you don't
necessarily want to keep credit card
details sitting in a database you might
choose to hold them in session state so
that will go away if the orders cancel
naturally now so so what is it why why
is it that we end up in this big ball of
mud scenario if we can do things like we
just described we're only sharing IDs
well it was this here right that's where
the problem started it was the sharing
of data as soon as we started to share
data between services it it got this
kind of ball rolling bounced down and it
got us kind of moving towards that that
possible end of that big ball of mud
scenario so this is what we want to
avoid want to avoid sharing data between
services so let's try and formalize a
little bit about what services actually
are and aren't first of all what a
service is not so a service which only
has functionality like a like a
calculation or a validation or something
like that that's not a service it is
just a is it is just a function
something that gives you cruds kind of
create read update delete functionality
on records that's just a database it's
not a service and really importantly
just because you put HTTP on front of a
database it doesn't suddenly make it a
service it's not some kind of magic dust
you sprinkle on a database and go hey
presto we've got a service now it's
still just the database we've just
changed the kind of technical access
point into it a service is the technical
authority for a specific business
capability the word business is really
important here
services are aligned along business
capabilities they are aligned along
business rules and not technical rules
and because all the code we write
belongs to some kind of business
capability I mean we don't we don't just
write code for fun right or I mean
sometimes if you know your projects
going to fail you can just kind of go
and learn rust or something but if you
in a normal mode of operation all the
code you write is for some specific
business capability that's what were
paid to do so it then follows if
services are the technical authorities
for business capabilities all code must
be
in some kind of service right so nothing
is left over after identifying services
if we look at systems versus services
these are two very different things
so sometimes we might have a mobile app
a back-end app a Java portal or
something like that now it's very
tempting to say well why don't we just
say that each of these are our services
right we've got a front-end service a
back-end service I'm sure we've all
heard that at some time the back-end
service right but the thing is services
operate along a different dimension they
are business aligned which means they
can cut across all these kind of
different technical layers now the
implication of that is that service one
here may have a jar may have an
objective-c component which ships into a
mobile app it may have a dotnet
component which ships into a dotnet
back-end it might have a Java compiler
which ships into this portal it's a it's
a many-to-many relationship so systems
can consist of components from many
services a service can consist of
components shipped into many systems I
sometimes think of it when if you think
about when you when you're playing with
a Lego and you know how you start off
with that kind of green board and if
you're really obsessive like I was when
I played with Lego I'd have my bricks
sorted into different piles so like the
big pieces the middle pieces and the
small pieces and then I kind of pick
bricks from each pile and kind of build
a house or something on the board and
that's my system right that's very much
how we very much is very much the
relationship between systems and
services services are logical design
time concerns with Business Alliance and
Riis systems are physical runtime
concerns aligned along technical
boundaries it's very important to make
that this association so if we try and
dig into a typical domain and look at
how we tease out these different
boundaries we might first of all see
something like this right so we speak to
our technical our business stakeholders
and they say we've got product and we
sell this products to customers
so one of the kind of intuitive things
we do is we get around the whiteboard
and we write write customer product into
boxes and we start from there and then
the business tell us things like
customer has a first name customer has a
last name customer has a status and it
seems natural then to kind of code some
entities which represent those things so
we can we can really write our code in
the business language but the thing is
what we want to be doing is we want to
be looking inside those entities so we
want to be looking at what is the
relationship between first name last
name and status for instance why are
they in the same place now there's a
really good technique for this called
anti requirements the interesting thing
about business stakeholders is they
often don't know what they want but they
will almost always know what they don't
want so you can ask really dumb sounder
questions like okay if the customers
last name is 20 characters or more
doesn't affect their status and the
business will turn around like look at
you and say you have no idea about this
domain at all have you that is so stupid
not only would we never do that but no
in no company in our tie industry would
do something is so ridiculous now if you
hear that you've basically struck gold
because what that means is the business
have just told you a stable business
rule they've said that there's no
relationship with a cut with a
customer's name and their status that
gives you a strong sign that you should
actually take those two things and put
them in two different places at this
stage of modeling we're looking to put
these things into different piles so
we're taking all the data we're kind of
breaking it up into its bits and we're
trying to put it in different piles of
things and this can eventually lead us
to to discovering where our service
boundaries are what we can do now is we
can say well customer status it's
sitting there all its own looking lonely
so what is customer status what do we
use customer status for and they'll say
oh well we use that to work out the
price so when someone's actually going
to pay for something if they're are
loyal customer or you know if they're
are kind of somewhere the bronze silver
gold hierarchy will give them a discount
or something like that so
okay so customer state has got something
to do with price I'm not exactly sure
how they relate yet but let's put them
in the same pile right we've got a
strong intuition they belong somehow
together then we can look at what we've
got left we've got name a description of
the product
well the description circuit should
somehow kind of complement that bid the
name if it's a luxury something
something you want the description to
say why it's a luxury something so we're
going to put those in the same pile over
here now you can see now that we've
ended up with a very different model to
what we had at the beginning and that's
because we're looking at the behaviors
and the use cases and the scenarios
we're not thinking and entity turns this
is what modeling is about modeling is
not about tangible things but our brains
are kind of hardwired for those tangible
things we like to look for things that
we can kind of recognize and hold on to
like a customer and a product we like to
start off at the higher level we don't
want the business to tell us all the
details to start off with let's just
start a high level okay
customers and products let's draw those
two boxes first and then that's dig into
the details later we need to turn that
practice upside down it's not the high
level entities that readers that lead us
down the right path we need to be
looking at the field not the entity
looking at the use cases and the
behaviour that's all data that takes
part in those behaviors that will lead
us to a very different model at the
beginning I said customer has a first
name customer has a last name customer
has a status if you hear yourself saying
that and look for that phrase in the
middle look for that has a if you hear
yourself saying has a it's a strong
indication you're thinking about an
entity first approach rather than use
cases another thing to really watch out
for at this stage another common pitfall
is naming things too early resist the
temptation to try and name these three
these three things too early I often say
that you should just give them kind of
meaningless names like red green and
yellow to start with or it can mean
names of planets or names of something
else but try not to give them business
many full names the problem with giving
things names early is that those names
get in the way so you'll end up having
conversations around the whiteboard and
someone will say something like okay
hang on stop that thought can't possibly
belong in there because that's billing
or they'll say oh I I know exactly where
this thing belongs it's an inventory the
problem is that you'll be tempted to put
things in the wrong places or not put
things into places just because of the
names you've chosen to assign to them so
do the naming much later once you've
gone down
once you've once you've done more of
this modeling or you've even got things
into production then take a look at the
different piles and then think about
what would what you would name that try
not to do it early sometimes it's it's
even better just to never give
meaningful names at all I've done that
and one of the teams that I was
previously in we used cozy monsters so
the most famous one is Godzilla and then
there's other ones like Mothra and
batter and all these things we just said
we're gonna leave those names in place
forever we're not gonna try and give
them meaningful names because many full
names we actually discovered on another
project really got in the way now that's
also easier if you're working in a bit
more of an abstract domain so that was
actually in in a bank and it was all to
do with trading on financial markets now
as an individual I don't really do a lot
of trading or financial markets and all
this was more abstract so it's more
obvious that or it's less tempting to
try and assign names early with
something like customers and products or
something more familiar it's often more
tempting but we need to try and resist
that temptation so how can we use his
techniques on a bit more of a realistic
than mine so let's look at Hotel again
we've also kind of stayed in hotels at
some point now and again here it's
tempting when you start looking at Hotel
domain to start drawing boxes and a
whiteboard things like rooms guests
bookings you know it's very intuitive to
start at the entity at that kind of
entity first model but we need to resist
that right we need to start looking at
the use cases so the first use case
we're going to look at is
so when you search for a room it will
tell you things like the room type
details about the room and a price and
this will be for certain dates right so
from the from and to date these are the
room types that are available and
importantly is it is a room type okay so
you don't book room for two three you
book a superior room or an economy room
if we look at the data that we've got on
this screen or what let's have a let's
have a think about what is it that we
need to say that a particular room type
is available on the certain set of dates
well first of all we have this notion of
room type and at the moment all we
really need is an ID right so we've got
a room type ID we don't need to model
further than that right now and we then
need to know a kind of from and to date
right so we need to know the actual
dates that the persons are looking for
and we need to know for a particular
room type how much capacity we've got of
that room of that room type and what
makes a room type available or not it's
the current amount of bookings all right
so we need some kind of booking ID in
here as well now this is not a table
it's not a database table but you can
kind of see that using a combination of
this data so from and to dates room type
ID how much we've got of that room type
how many bookings we've got for that
room time from here we can work out how
much of a room type is available in a
certain set of dates the next thing is
the price now the price of a room isn't
really affected by whether it's
available or not I know you might be
thinking of airlines where as it gets
closer to the day and less seats are
available they put the prices up but
hotels don't actually tend to work like
that they tend to just sell big blocks
of rooms to booking.com for instance and
once the price is fixed the price is
fixed so we're going to put price in
another pile right we're going to put it
over here with room type ID into another
pile and one thing that can affect the
price is the specific date right so we
might charge more at weekends we might
charge less at weekends it depends where
the hotel is isn't a holiday resort or
not as in the city so we need some kind
of notion of
they in this pile as well because it's
their price varies with date and then
we've got other things like the the name
in the description and the photo so we
want these things to kind of complement
each other if it's a luxury room we want
the photo to look luxurious and we want
the description to explain why it's a
luxury room and why some more expensive
now the next part of this workflow is
actually selecting this room now
what's really important is that the
price that is shown here and I know
that's very small but that says 3937 NOK
for the entire stay we want to show that
same price in the next screen and we
select that room now the this is now
showing an average price per night I
think this is probably the most
expensive nights in that stay but the
important thing is that this 3900 NOK
here is the same 3900 NOK here and
that's really important because you
don't want someone to click through and
say and the prices suddenly go up right
they'll be very bad at user experience
in fact there are laws around that right
if that happens that would actually be
counted as false advertising right so
you can't advertise at one price click
through and see another price so what
that means is that we've now somehow
need to associate a price with this
workflow that this user is actually
having with our site right now now
remember what I said about creating the
ID upfront if we create an idea up from
here before when we get to this screen
so when they actually search we can
create a booking ID right now that might
sound a bit strange because the bookings
not really finalized until you've paid
for it but we've already talked about
having that what would some people would
consider redundant data early on early
on the process so we can create the
booking ID right here and we can
associate that booking idea with the
price on this screen so when we go here
we've got the same booking ID and we can
receive the same price on this next
screen so the question now is how do we
associate the booking ID with the price
we've got two options
we can move the price from green to
white we can copy it we can duplicate
the price from green to white or we can
move the booking ID from white to green
now price again might seem like a simple
thing it might be you might think oh
that's just a number it's just the price
per night or price for the whole booking
but price can be a lot more complicated
if we look back here I think it was on
this one
look at all these different pricing
options standard rates prepay and save
deals and packages price is actually a
lot more complicated than one number so
price then is inherently a more unstable
business concept because as your
business as your business you just think
of great wonderful new ways to kind of
make people buy hotel rooms they might
come up with different pricing
structures so we don't want to copy the
less stable business abstraction from
green to white let's copy the much more
stable business abstraction of the ID
from white to green and if you think
about it an ID isn't really data right
an idea is just kind of like a pointer
to something with business meaning
business users don't really care what's
inside to do it or if they do that
something's really gone wrong but an
idea is essentially just kind of a
pointer into something which has
business meaning but it doesn't really
have any business meaning itself then
the next stage of the workflow is to
actually book your room and this is
where you put your details in your first
name your last name your email address
etc and at this point you could
potentially use anti requirements to
find out where this goes you could say
well is any of this stuff affected by
the guest info so guest in the guest
name begins with s does that affect the
room description or the capacity or the
price and the business will say stop are
some of these stupid questions
it is completely unrelated then you know
you can put it in another pile alright
so we put guest info down here with the
booking ID again now at this point you
might think well when you actually come
round to to kind of implementing this
you might discover that this yellow
service down here at the bottom all it
really is is crud
guest info just creating reading
updating and deleting guest info so you
might say well is this really a service
does it really belong in its own another
service boundary and if there are really
no business rules in there you might
choose to fold this back up to one of
the other services
now again take a look at this model and
then think about how this might look if
we did if we drawn bookings and guests
and rooms on a whiteboard all right this
has led us down to a very different
model than the entity model would have
and the thing is that because we've all
stayed in hotels it's really tempting to
not even talk to a domain expert we've
all stayed in hotels we know how they
work we know you can book them they can
stay in rooms so you just start modeling
this stuff yourself but the thing is
you're doing that from me from the point
if you have a customer of a hotel you're
not doing it from the point of view of
running a hotel so even in those more
obvious domains it's always it's it's
almost always a really good idea to have
a domain expert in the room so again use
cases details scenarios that's what's
led us down here not entities entities
would have ended up with a very
different model has anyone here read
Eric Evans blue domain driven design
book quite a few of you right so he
talks about entities are there quite a
lot right the thing is that Eric
actually said since then he said he
wished he put the entities part in the
second half of the book because everyone
read the first half with the entities
and that crews got all excited and
started coding and then kind of didn't
read the second half of the book so he
wished he'd changed that order
later on he actually said he wished he'd
put it in the appendix later on he
actually said he wished he'd left it all
together so the thing is we've got very
transfixed on this whole entity approach
and we kind of jump on that as a
modeling approach but entities lead us
down the wrong path I'll even go ahead
and say it entities are bad use cases
data field scenarios behaviors good they
lead us down the right path if you want
to use entities within a service
boundaries that kind of implementation
deeds are fine but are the service
boundary modeling level not a very good
tool to use
another domain another interesting
tomatoes insurance so is they one here
work in insurance must be at least some
just a couple of lucky people so
insurance companies are often modeled
around the the service boundaries of a
fun office and a back office so the
front office and an insurance company is
really it's really kind of all about
fear their job is to kind of make people
afraid enough that they buy more
insurance if I got that more or less
right
in fact the I was in I was in Russia not
long ago speaking some people about this
and they told me that the the word for
insurance and Russian actually has the
word fear in it so so it is kind of true
the back office is very different
they're the guys that deal with claims
so when you actually something bad
happens you make a claim they get a
claim form in and their job is to
actually work out how little they can
pay you in the face of that claim it
actually sounds a bit cutthroat but
that's how a successful insurance
company works its maximum money in
minimum money out and then we make money
so what you might see is something like
this you might see domain you might see
service boundaries drawn around those
front and back offices so we've got a
policy service here and we've got a
claim service now I really don't know
much about the insurance industry I
don't know anything about running an
insurance company but I can look at
these straightaway and I can say these
are the wrong boundaries the reason for
that is let's look at us let's look at a
typical use case imagine you make a
claim on your house insurance the first
thing that the claims service is gonna
do is to a whole bunch of request
response to the policy service to find
out the details of the policy they're
going to read for all that fine print
and work out how they can get away with
not paying you or how they can minimize
the amount of money they have to pay you
and it works the other way so for
instance if you make a lot of claims in
your car insurance the next time you buy
a policy that policy price is going to
go up so when they're selling car
insurance from the front office I might
do
Oh load request response to the back
office to find out what claims you've
made all that chattiness going between
the two services is Indyk is indicative
of tight coupling right there's a lot of
data being there's a lot of data share
between the two services they have to
know about the internals of each other
quite a lot now it's all very easy to
say you know they're all wrong but how
can we find the right ones well that's a
lot harder so and this and this process
can take a long time so when we looked
at the hotel domain I kind of showed you
I kind of Illustrated find out what it's
like to find boundaries but it doesn't
feel like that when you're doing this in
real life so if you are called into a
company as a consultant you could easily
say at the beginning oh yeah the service
boundary is all wrong what are the right
ones well I really don't know and a lot
of time can go past before you do find
the right ones is come it can be a slow
process finding service boundaries is a
kind of it feels like you're kind of
bumbling around in the dark to kind of
trying to feel your way around you may
not make progress for quite some time
but eventually you might get some kind
of insight some kind of glimmer of hope
you know I think I've got something here
you might realize that home insurance
actually isn't really that related to
travel insurance or car insurance so
when you have a car accident
you don't show someone your sofa they're
very different use cases and then you
discover that a better way of modeling
this might be home insurance travel
insurance and car insurance so then you
go back to your business stakeholders
and you say right guess what I've got it
I've got it and I've got some
earth-shattering news home insurance
it's different to travel insurance car
insurance is also different travel
insurance and the business will say to
you how long has it taken you to work
out something which I've known for my
entire career how much have we just paid
you to come in and tell us something so
obvious now the thing is again when you
hear that you've struck gold right
because when the business says oh but
that's obvious
you've probably got the right boundaries
now you might think well okay well why
didn't we just shortcut
why don't we just say to the business in
the first place what are your service
boundaries and they would have or how is
your business organized and they would
have said oh you know home insurance
travel insurance and car insurance and
okay great those are our service
boundaries off we go problem is that
this up here was also obvious and the
thing is that when you talk to a
business person there are many different
dimensions along which you could split
this you might get lucky they might say
to you oh yo we've got home insurance
car insurance and travel insurance and
aiko off you go or they might say oh
yeah we've got a front office in the
back office
well they might say oh you've got
customers and we've got products we sell
to customers so you don't know if you
start at that high level you don't know
if you if you if you're cutting things
across the right dimension it's another
example of how starting at that high
level can lead you down the wrong path
it's not that the detail reveals itself
from the high level it's that the high
level is revealed from the detail you
need to go down to the detail and you
might ask well do I really need to go to
that level of detail and the answer is
yes you do it is it's only when you look
at the data that takes place in the
interactions of a certain use case that
then you discover what data is coupled
to what data
it's a bottom-up approach and that
brings us neatly onto organizations so
the front office back office thing was
an example of an organizational boundary
now at one time it may have been it may
have been possible to model services
around organizational boundaries if you
think about the old days before things
were automated with the computers data
used to exist in filing cabinets so the
cost of accessing data was expensive a
filing cabinet might be on the other
side of the building so to get some data
you actually have to walk across the
other side of the building to get it so
because of that people tended to be
located next sir later so all the data
that I need will be kind of surrounding
me in filing cabinets and then to do
some kind of job function I will go to
my filing cabinet look through something
write out some kind of form put it in my
outbox
and then some kind of trolley person
will come along and kind of shuffle it
over to someone else pivot their inbox
they would go to their data in their
filing cabinets get that thing maybe
write something tick off a box put it in
their outbox and so forth the rest of
the workflow so because of the cost of
data access companies were almost forced
to be service oriented right they were
forced to encapsulate their data in
different departments but for that
reason now we came along with our clever
computers we put a workstation on
everyone's desk and a big database in
the middle and all of a sudden anyone
can access anything so what we did was
we took away the one constraint which
which which which was forcing companies
to be service-oriented so what tends to
happen now is that managers and
companies can tend to kind of pick jobs
from around the company then kind of
swallow up job functions into their
departments because really anyone can
access anything someone's I've got right
permissions so the modern Department and
a company has kind of become a kind of
mini Kingdom where managers kind of a
kind of empire building and building up
more boxes underneath them in the org
chart and the problem with that is it's
not a stable business boundary so when
modeling services we want to be looking
for stable business rules now I've
worked in organizations before where my
organizational unit my team has changed
six seven eight times in a year that's a
very unstable business boundary I don't
want to be changing my business my set
my service boundaries six seven eight
times a year so be very careful be aware
be very wary of the organizational
boundary it's often not a very good tool
for us to use and that is a real shame
right because it'll be nice if you could
just go into a company and say oh you've
got finance billing shipping let's just
those are our service boundaries and
we're done it's a real shame it'll be
nice if we could do that
but that rarely works in practice
so I I do need to of course talk a
little bit about microservices now I'm
sure you've all heard a lot about micro
service is ready in this conference I
think a lot of good things have come out
of micro services we've got these this
concept of these nice individual
isolated deployable units with nice
crisp responsibilities and boundaries
that we can deploy in various places and
use things like docker and stuff like
that so I think there's a lot of good
things there but I do have one big
concern I'll try to illustrate it so as
we've seen a lot of our careers are kind
of a big part of our jobs is battling
against the big ball of mud this is the
thing that we want to kind of stay away
from I want to avoid so we read about
micro services and that tells us that we
should try and split things up into
smaller components so we split things up
in the same 5 micro services and this is
nicer now because we can think of these
things individually we can look at them
one at a time but then we read oh well
fives not really enough you need at
least 10 micro services so you split
things up a bit more and now we've got
what is it 13 up there and now we think
okay we must be doing micro services now
now we read a bit more literature and it
says things like well each micro service
should really be small enough that you
can rewrite it within a week or or even
worse something like it should only be
200 lines along or something out of that
so you spoke up even more and you end up
with a lot more micro services now
that's all well and good and that
actually looks quite nice but the thing
is eventually the business will come to
you with a requirement and you realize
that you mean to make a change up here
and it needs some data from down here so
these micro services are nicely defined
they've got a nice crisp boundaries but
we don't have any other kind of service
boundaries defined here because the
micro services are the boundaries
themselves so there's nothing stopping
us from making that call so we make it
call from one micro service to another
and we roll it out and everything's good
sooner or later we discover that we need
through the same thing again we'll need
some data up here from something down
here we make that call again and we roll
it out right
you know where this is going right we've
seen this picture before over time and
again no one sets out to do this over
time we've got micro-services calling
microservices calling microservices and
this is the same picture that we saw
before right that is deliberate and as
we've seen might as well take the lines
out we Mauser just draw a bunch of
things a bunch of microservices we've
seen that we may as well just take the
the boxes out and just draw one big
thing and we're back to our big ball of
mud but it's a big ball of mud with a
difference this time you've got a
hundreds micro-services running on a
hundred docker containers they're all
talking through travel over Network and
we've ended up with a big ball of mud
microservices addition now we want to be
this is not what we want we want to be
avoiding this we want bit we want
business alliance service boundaries we
want these things to have light lines of
communication between them and what is
it that goes between them
it's IDs right now if we look within
those service boundaries we may have
smaller autonomous components so it may
make sense for one of these services
basically our fins are five different
components one of them may just have one
component another others may have many
more and as we've seen systems are not
services systems our systems are
composed from picking component from
different services interval into
somebody that's deployable so we might
pick something from here something from
here and something from here and deploy
that into a actual physical system now
you may be also thinking well isn't it
possible within one of these service
boundaries to build a mini ball of mud
now I'm not going to say that that is
impossible you know if you're determined
enough you can build a mess using any
kind of architectural approach you know
this one this one down here on the
bottom right is starting to get a bit
complex however what I will say is it's
it's it's much less likely because we've
we've already split these things up
along business boundaries to increase
our understand
of the use cases and to be able to
isolate changes to introduce new
functionality into one place we tend to
split these things up internally within
service boundaries through Barrett for
very different reasons if we look at
this service down here this might have
something to do with bank accounts and
it might have a few different
responsibilities like creating bank
account statements or locking accounts
of fraud so let's say we think there's
some fraudulent activity on the account
we want to lock that account immediately
we don't want any more transactions to
happen now let's say we send a thousand
messages to that to that service to say
crate bank statements then we send a
message to say lock this account now we
don't want the locking of that account
to be queued up but hide behind the
thousand messages to create bank
statements so we split that up into two
different components we have one
component of statements we have another
component for fraud each of them has
their own cue we send a thousand a
thousand messages of Satan to the bank
statements thing to create bank
statements we send one message to fraud
because on different cues the message to
fraud gets straight there and that gets
done straightaway the statements
component we might roll out to two
machines just for failover the fraud
thing we might roll out to ten machines
ten computing consumers we might
elastically scale it whatever's needed
to to make the SLA of locking accounts
of fraud now each of these things you
could call a micro service if you want
to call each of those things a micro
service I I'm no problem with that at
all I don't I don't really like the word
micro service I think a part of part of
the problem is in the name first of all
the word micro which means that size is
the important factor which I don't think
it is and service right so service tends
to get conflated service is a very
overloaded word but because I called
micro services it distracts us from
thinking about the business aligned
bandar ease we get fixated with physical
boundaries around deployable units
instead of letting go of that and
allowing ourselves to draw boundaries
around business capabilities instead so
call them micro services reveal if you
want I prefer something like autonomous
components something like that okay so
we're getting towards the end now before
I wrap up I will recommend to you that
you have a look at this if you want to
look at this in more detail and you want
to see some more use cases this is
actually a video package which I've put
together this is a see this is a CEO of
particular software guy called OD de
Haan this is set of videos that he
produces and they are an extract from
them from a much larger five-day course
that he runs a few times each year so go
there you can register for free and grab
that video package and hear more about
this kind of thing so just to wrap up
one really important thing to say is
that service-oriented architecture like
anything else is not a silver bullet it
is not a golden hammer I guess a few of
you have probably read the Gang of Four
patterns book at some stage so do you
remember when you read about those new
patterns and then you went back to work
and you started writing everything using
that new pattern so the same thing
applies here and it applies everywhere
this is not something just to use
blindly on everything it'll magically
solve your problems there was a time to
use service-oriented architecture I
think the biggest example of that is
startups so is anyone here working in a
start-up or a startup ish kind of thing
a couple of you startups can also be not
necessarily new companies there can be
new things within a company so a new an
existing large company might choose to
kind of spin up a new project kind of in
a startup fashion so you might find
yourself in these kind of situations now
and then and the thing is if someone
comes to me and says well you know I'm
in a startup now and I'm gonna do
service drawings a good architecture I'm
gonna get more my service boundaries
right from the start we're gonna do it
all perfectly then I usually say well
I've got some bad news because you have
to be very careful using this kind of
architecture in the stuff
and the reason for that is we want to be
modeling around stable business rules
now startups don't know what their
businesses are for at least the first
few years so if you look at Facebook for
instance Facebook is a media company all
it does is puts eyeballs in front of
media and it sells those eyeballs for
advertisers it's quite a classic media
media company model with one crucial
differences I don't actually have to
produce any content so it's an
incredibly lucrative model but this is
the thing with when you're in a start-up
you kind of you've got ideas and you
know that you can make money with these
things somehow but you don't really know
how yet you know that Twitter's another
great example so you kind of just
spreading your toys out on the floor and
you're seeing seeing what you can do
with them and seeing what you can build
with them and it's not really too much
of a problem if the if the if the code
that you write over that phase kind of
matches that and is a little bit messy
and is a bit of a ball of mud because
the thing is if you try and model if you
try and look for service boundaries
early on that phase you're gonna be
looking at things which are not yet
stable business rules you might you've
been doing a lot of guesswork around
things that could change and probably
will change so in either case even if
you build it using some kind of service
boundaries or you kind of build just a
thing that does something somehow you're
probably gonna have to rewrite it in
either case so you're not really losing
anything by just creating a bit of a
mess at the beginning so my advice on
that is be very careful about trying to
use service-oriented architecture and
trying to look for service boundaries
too early on and a kind of start-up
scenario so I guess that brings us to
the end I hope that's been useful and
that's given you something to think
about when when you go back and think
about your own systems and as I said I'm
gonna be around for the rest of the
conference so do feel free feel free to
grab me and ask me for more
clarification or any of these things if
you think some of these things are
really just weird and wacky and won't
work you know do challenge me on them as
well
that's when I think a lot of the most
interesting conversations happen so I'll
be around you know please please do feel
free to grab me
so enjoy the rest of the conference I
hope you've enjoyed that I've really
enjoyed speaking to you and thank you
very much
[Applause]